all right morning guys so we're gonna do
a regular workout here we're gonna do 20
minutes again so I can't really say
we're gonna do a 10 minute warm-up and a
10 minute workout because we're gonna
kind of workout in a little more organic
waste this is a little more how I would
work out if I wasn't teaching a class so
we can kind of do that and then we'll do
about a 10 minute meditation when we're
done all right here we go
yeah wait belting out feet just out
funny bring up just a little bit to the
other graph right cross them over the
top underneath some cross movie
a tight flutters little babies and hold
it out feet up high how you can't hold
them up hold them up
and we're knees in the way back down
good
neck up off the ground keep your net
head off the ground the whole time bring
this go ear your shoulder so back boy
look here shoulder back and forth it's
off the ground it's not touching ground
you can head up and down to the ground
other direction
good lady on the red stick so totally
relax your neck right now let all the
tension of your neck here he felt Street
and City up and touch those toes back
down did he go that's just toes
ah
huama up good job over on your stomach
hands underneath your shoulders
we're gonna copra up those drinks that
pour out so just a bunch of attracting
of the core now we're gonna let it
stretch out
he's supposed to be 105 day so just
already warming up and back down good
job come into the balls of the feet push
straight up hold the position it's a
nice straight back hold that position
so I'm half way up in the air you go two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
drop your knees sit back if you're doing
this you're stretching your laptop so
inside your back and feel it being
stretched out so I'm pushing my chest
still right now and reaching my arm
towards over there boney burns I'm
reaching forward with them right here
push my chest at the same time stretch
it all through my lats
all right hands on the hips try to keep
this nice position balls of the feet
balance up good bring one leg out and
shake it back and forth if we can find
our balance you have a hard time Phelps
don't watch me right now I'm all over
the place Eric speaking back and forth
dizzy today all right other side back
and forth
back and forth back and forth
good job right Cermak little figure
eight someone kick my leg up sideways
sir go down the back just my ankle the
other day it's not liking me so make a
little figure eight here
so I'm making a circle one direction and
coming back and circle the other
direction outside
it's hard to challenge my brain it is
for my feet my pellet it's my foot
staying off the ground the whole time
just taking a little figure 8 it'll be
great good ok one foot up so do the tree
pose get it she posed there well then
Clayton there we go
and other side tree pose
nice deep squat hold this position so
when we begin here feet on the ground
and drop my butt to the ground so it
slows I can possibly be in this position
heels down if you're like this it's not
the worst thing in the world but work to
get those heels down okay from this
position reach up and over like I'm
reaching for something over that way
other side up
but over notice if you have any
asymmetry in this right meeting my right
side is kind of hang it up a little bit
- my left sides a lot freer so notice
anything you have try notice where
you're feeling hung up right sit your
shoulders if you're relaxed your lower
back what's what's going on
nice stretch stretch Direction good
advice you get pretty warm by now okay
see you playing like this okay
so video hands down in front heat up
hands down in front speed up
I get one more frame and it's gonna cook
feet up then back back back
good arms out three now we go back one
two three stand up shake your legs out
good nice fly position elbows on the
knees rocking back and forth a little
bit first ten minutes
halfway through this workout I mean one
side heel down on this side footing toe
down on that side and the other side
the other side the other side the foot
down this time and the other side over
back over over over you coming up just a
little bit higher like this rest your
hands on the knees relax into it
rock back and forth this is nice easy
gentle moving right now
so we're taking the stress off the
muscles the way we just use them kind of
locking out of my frame to do this down
you jump into the middle spread the feet
and sitting back is it like me I've been
working out drinking as much as you
should have all right we're in keep us
flat plain here put your feet along your
knees so lift your feet aren't there
they're here that's cool put your feet
on your knees slide your hand out and
grab one ankle it's like your hand up
and grab the other so wherever you're at
let your hand out one ankle other back
and forth
real easy notice the stretch you're
getting through your lateral lumbar
right so your lower spine but most of
all on the side of your body here like
so depending where your lap starts
connect in and back and forth
all right we're gonna feed in those
knees it out are you gonna need a little
bit of room for this next one here in a
second so probably not any more even
you've had to use so far but here's that
get where you monkey rolls so hands
underneath the feet they're all off to
the side around and back up do it again
same direction around back up you'll be
closest to about 120 or 720p but we're
going back the other way now so yeah I'm
back room where I started and go the
other way
good job all right on your back feet up
in the air like this might be it so make
it look like it but when he's a straight
right oh but my my knees straight so my
leg locked out like this a nice straight
leg okay so here legs are straight my
toes are pointed I'm gonna make a little
circle so I'm drawing a little circle
other direction not to be Circle City on
12 inch in diameter circle he will not
keep
good now reach up for your feet keep
reaching reaching reaching reaching keep
reaching
good job arms down keep them to like
your flat on the mat now I'm gonna sit
up but I'm not let myself all the way up
here breasts not gonna get up to that
position so I'm here sit up my stomach's
contracted I'm just gonna keep sitting
up so I'm not gonna allow myself to roll
one way bones you like this I'm just
gonna keep here pushing pushing pushing
hold on can't get anywhere totally relax
your core let all the stress out of it
that's it so we're relaxing and not no
stress see if you can make their stomach
completely relaxed good right we're
gonna go up again
and down rest completely relax let all
the stress out of semi wholly relax
[Music]
we'll see right here it's hard work and
looking rough your stomach again means
bent keep our spine straight and push
straight up right so nice Street
spotting when I'm doing this I'm gonna
track my elbows along my ribcage
so it was tracking the ribcage here as I
go down a little track along the rib
cage that go up go all the way down flat
hand off the ground and resting right
then hands down all the way back up we
repeat these all the way down your time
you can come up back down I'll lift
you're nice and straight keep your back
straight while you're doing this damn
damn damn oh damn stay down here like
this
take your hands cube out straight like
Superman
just like Superman you know gives you
out behind my back right but not
touching my back oh wow
that high one out in front seasons are
back be high
good job okay nice and flat hands by the
shoulders resting right now on the balls
of my feet
everything's rested totally resting
good job I came here when I pick my left
hand up put my right foot through so
left hand up right foot through sit back
so I'm kind of like a reverse push-up
position here now I'm gonna pick up my
right hand put my left foot through and
I'm back down to the forward lean then
the reverse that left hand right foot
now left hand without break-in now left
hand breakfast three good let's go right
foot right hand left foot right hand
left foot left hand right foot right
foot right hand left foot left hand
right foot
but beanies sitting back let's again
laughs again and rocking up good all
right
sitting flapping with your shin box
position so box position is one
foot in front like this back foot out
toe pointing out right so money this
book is out like this it's like a little
kid watch TV unfortunately so
relax my hip here and let my foot sit
out or my leg sit down here wall my hips
relaxing I'm not doing any of this in my
day all in my hip right so let's drink
is happening buddy hip breaking quite
done yet good sitting there straight
it's a hip out is already nice and warm
right now good time to stretch good your
fianc right now I'm leaning into that
hip a little bit trying to get more hip
straight I feel zero pressure on my knee
feel everything in my hip I don't want
strike out my hip
good other side reverse our chin tuck
position this foot out front its leg out
stretch in here nothing in my tank
everything in my hip yeah your knees
hurting bring the pressure off of it
however you need to right so you wanna
bring the pressure off of that knee so
all the stretch is in your hip
yeah all right
with no medication here we're gonna do
looks like about eight minutes and 39
seconds
so we'll medicate a little longer than
this goes off so somewhere around ten
minutes probably okay
so nice relaxed position we're gonna do
another observational meditation it's
hardest for your mind let go of
everything so just be now and in the
moment thoughts are going to arise
that's fine it's natural perfectly cool
let them arise let them leave
that's what thoughts do don't put any
effort into the thought don't follow the
thought allow your mind to be here now
this is relatively easy in lots of ways
when you're doing this you have to
juggle a bunch of stuff but you know
when you're freaked out your mind's
anxious and trying to make all kinds of
stuff happen this is a useful skill to
be able to have so it's relatively easy
to practice in a calm situation like
this some ways it's hard because you'll
have something else to focus on which
which helps but learning to control your
mind from here will help you control
your mind and lots of other situations
so seated meditation we're gonna do
probably a little less than 10 minutes
three bills and three bills out here we
go
[Music]
you
okey guys so that's it for today I will
see you on Thursday have a good one
see you later take care